foreign
ke helps you protect your resources in
your gke clusters creating critical
backups should you ever need to perform
a point in time restore to the same
cluster or to a new cluster that you've
created
so let's take a look at how to enable
this first we'll want to enable backup
for gke's API within a Google Cloud
project backup for gke is its own
managed service with its own API
separate from gke
with that done let's jump over to gke
Cluster we'll start with this cluster
named prod now this cluster could hold
all sorts of resources things that can
be scoped to the cluster like roles or
custom resource definitions or things
scope to namespaces like stateless
workloads and state full workloads with
their respective State stored in
persistent volumes as an example this
cluster is running WordPress in its own
namespace with a WordPress pod and a
database pod storing data for WordPress
using persistent volumes with backup for
gke we can take proactive steps to
create backups of these resources
today we'll be enabling backup for gke
in this existing cluster it's important
to note that performing this change is
non-disruptive to the resources already
running in cluster but of course you can
also have backup for gke enabled at
cluster creation time
with this operation now complete let's
take a look at how we can shape our
backups using backup plans
when using backup for gke it's highly
likely you'll want to perform a backup
multiple times over the lifetime of your
cluster and your environment the scope
of what each of these individual backups
are made up of are defined by a backup
plan so let's create our first
backup plans map to a specific cluster
so we'll select the cluster we saw
earlier prod
and we're going to name this our first
backup plan
and then we'll want to Define what
region we want to host our backups in
next we'll want to configure the scope
of resources that our backups associated
with this backup plan will capture the
scope of each backup plan always
includes cluster scope resources
essentially resources that are not
scoped to a single namespace
atop that we can also choose to backup
all namespaces in the cluster and their
respective resources
if we want backups to be more granular
we can choose specific namespaces in the
cluster to back up which is especially
helpful if our cluster uses namespaces
as a logical boundary between either
teams or Services some of which might
need backups and some of which may not
in this case we can see that we have a
WordPress namespace for the WordPress
pods we showed earlier
finally to perform the most granular
backup possible backup for gke
introduces a kubernetes custom resource
called a protected application you can
use this to group together a specific
set of resources in a namespace to
backup and you can also specify logic to
run pre or post backup to learn more
about how to compose a protected
application manifest check out the link
in the description
as you can see we can specify this
protected application method in our
backup plan but for our first backup
let's just capture the entire cluster
now that we've gotten the scope settled
the next important aspect of our backup
plan is what specific resources and data
to capture by default within the scope
of the backup plan we capture all
resource definitions in kubernetes
except Secrets you'll need to opt into
that explicitly in your backup plan if
you want them included
separate from kubernetes resource
definitions we also perform backups of
data stored using persistent volumes
for example if you are using GCE
persistent disk to store data that your
workload produces
backup for gke will perform volume
snapshots to capture the underlying disk
State at the time of backup
finally by default we will encrypt the
backup using a Google manage encryption
key but you can also specify your own
customer managed encryption key to be
used
now while you can manually perform a
backup based on a backup plan at any
time you can also specify a chronic
expression to perform backups
automatically on a regular Cadence
for example this Crown expression here
specifies a backup to be performed based
on this backup plan every day at 3 pm
UTC
and since we're using a regular schedule
to perform backups we also need to
Define what's called a retention policy
this will specify how long backups are
retained before they are deleted in this
case we'll set it to 30 days
you can also use retention policies to
prevent deletion of backups for a time
to protect against things like malicious
user deletion or ransomware attacks you
can also lock down the editing of this
retention policy once the backup plan is
created
and after one final review we're ready
to create our first backup plan
now that it's created our cluster will
have regular backups captured based on
this backup plan
and while we hope we never have to
should there be an event where we need
to perform a restore of our clusters
resources we can use these backups to
implement a point in time restore to
learn more about getting started with
backup for gke check out the
documentation in the description and as
always thank you for your time
foreign
[Music]